>> COULD YOU IMAGINE THAT DOG A
THE G7?
AT THIS WEEKEND'S WESTERN
CONSERVATIVE SUMMIT HE HEADS
DONALD TRUMP IN A 2024
PRESIDENTIAL PREFERENCE STRAW
OLD.
FORMER VP MIKE PENCE CAME INTEN
INTO YOU COULD SEE THE LOOK ON
HIS FACE, RIGHT?
ACTUALLY, IT'S THE SAME LOOK HE
ALWAYS HAS.
ANYWAY, HE IS ONE OF AMERICA'S
MOST POPULAR GOVERNORS THANKS T
HIS WINDS ON FLORIDA'S ECONOMY
AND COVID RESPONSE IS ALSO A
BITER AND THAT'S CONNECTING WIT
NEWER REPUBLICANS WHO ARE MORE
RACIALLY DIVERSE, THE STORY A O
POLITICAL MAGAZINE ARGUES THAT
THE BARSTOOL OF THE GOP COULD
RECONFIGURE ITS CULTURAL
POLITICS FOR A GENERATION.
BARSTOOL HEAD WHO ENJOYS
TORMENTING LIBERALS ONLINE HAS
RANTED RENTED AGAINST COVID
LOCKDOWN THREATENED TO EMPLOYEE
AND EVEN ANNOUNCED A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN AND IF
TRUMP EXPOSED ANYTHING IT'S THA
LIBS ARE THE PARTY POOPERS, THE
PRO- COLLECTORS WHO CAN ROOF
RUIN OF PARTY FASTER THAN A
BACKED UP TOILET.
AND, THE MEDIA AND BIG TECH,
VOTERS ARE IN SEARCH OF REAL
CHANGE AND ARE LOOKING SOMEWHER
ELSE FOR IT IT'S LIKE GEORGE
WASHINGTON ONCE SAID TO HIS WIFE
, MARTHA, I CROSSED THE
DELAWARE SO DON'T WHY DON'T YOU
TAKE OUT THE GARBAGE, YOU OLD
BAG.
IT'S ONE OF HIS EARLIER MEMOIRS
CATS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T REMEMBER
THAT PART, BUT I DO.
IS IT TOO SOON TO CARE ABOUT
THIS, OR IS IT TOO LATE TO CARE
ABOUT THIS STUFF?
>> HAVING WORKED FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND KNOWING THE GOVERNOR
WELL, I THINK THEY'RE BOTH GOIN
TO BE AWESOME.
SO LET ME SAY THAT OVER AND OVE
AGAIN.
I DON'T PAY MUCH ATTENTION TO
THE DENVER DISCO WARRIORS UP
AHEAD OF TIME BECAUSE ALL THE
POLES GOT IT TOTALLY WRONG.
FOUR YEARS AGO.
>> YOU'RE A RACIST.
>> I AM A A RACIST.
>> YOU JUST ASSUMED A GENDER, B
THE WAY.
>> THEIR GENDER, HOW DARE YOU.
DID YOU TAG NAME HIM DID PRONOU
HIM?
>> IT'S IT.
>> OH MY GOD, WHAT AM I DOING?
I AM THE MOST DISGUSTING BIGOTE
PERSON.
>> NOW MY MOTHER IS CALLING ME.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
DO YOU THINK, IT IS A STRONG
STRONG PERSON, TRUMP COULD
PROBABLY MAKE IT OR BREAK IT AT
THIS POINT, HE COULD DECIDE ON
HIM OR DECIDE TO CHALLENGE AND.
>> WHO COULD, AND I THINK RIGHT
NOW HE IS EVEN EDGING OUT TRUMP
BECAUSE HE'S IN SUCH A GREAT
POSITION RIGHT NOW THIS YEAR,
AND THREE YEARS FROM NOW, THAT
COULD BE A VERY DIFFERENT STORY
RIGHT NOW HE HAS GREAT SUCCESS
RECORD ON COVID, ONE OF THE ONL
GOVERNORS TO DO THAT, AND HE HA
WEIGHED IN ON JUST ABOUT EVERY
POLICY ISSUE THAT REPUBLICAN
VOTERS CARE ABOUT ASCENDING
BORDER ASSISTANCE TO TEXAS AND
ARIZONA COMEY HE'S WEIGHED IN O
WOKE GENDER PRISM, CRITICAL RAC
THEORY, AND ALL OF THE THINGS
TAKING OVER THE REPUBLICAN
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW.
I AGREE THAT I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE TWO SOON TO DEFINITIVELY
SAY THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR GUY
IN 2024.
WHEN YOU TAKE BACK THE HOUSE, H
BECOME SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
>> HE DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO RUN
FOR THE HOUSE THAN TO BECOME TH
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE FOR THAT'S
WHAT THEY WERE SAYING.
>> WHY ARE YOU ALWAYS PUTTING M
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS MIX?
>> IT'S YOUR SHOW.
>> WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> HE'S ALREADY BEEN THE
PRESIDENT.
WOULD YOU SEE HIM TAKING A LOWE
SEAT EVEN IF IT'S JUST A
RECORDING.
, I WAS WRONG THE LAST TIME.
WE AMERICA'S DADDY, BUT HE ENDE
UP BEING AMERICA'S DEVIL.
>> HIS BIZARRO WORLD CUOMO.
>> EXACTLY.
>> CHADWICK IS RIGHT THAT TRUMP
WILL NOT GO FOR A JOB THAT IS
SMALLER THAN THE ONE HE HAD, WH
WOULD THEY CREATE A JOB CALLED
GREATER THAN THE PRESIDENT.
AND IT'S LIKE SO THIN TRUMP GOE
ALL TAKE THAT JOB.
>> YOU MEAN LIKE A KING?
>> AND WE FIGHT A WAR ABOUT THAT
?
>> I DIDN'T FIGHT THAT WAR.
>> TRUE.
I KIND OF LIKE THE IDEA OF
HAVING A KING.
WHERE A BIG ROBE.
I'D BE LIKE TO HANG OUT THERE
AND MAKE JOKES ALL THE TIME AND
PRAY THEY DON'T KILL ME.
ANSWER THE QUESTION, WHY ARE YO
EVADING THE QUESTION?
>> I THINK I DID ANSWER THE
QUESTION I DON'T THINK WE SHOUL
HAVE A KING.
>> YOU WORKED AT BARSTOOL.
>> I AM A WOMAN AND.
>> HARD TO BELIEVE THERE IS.
>> CRAZY BECAUSE I REALLY DO
EXUDE MASCULINE ENERGY, BUT
EVERY TIME I READ THESE ARTICLE
ABOUT BARSTOOL AND THIS HORRIBL
PLACE IT IS FOR WOMEN, AND LIKE
IT BLOWS MY MIND BECAUSE I HATE
TO BURST ANYONE'S BUBBLE, A LOT
OF PEOPLE HATE FIRST, BUT I HAD
NOTHING BUT THE MOST WONDERFUL
EXTREMES THE ENTIRE TIME I
WORKED THERE.
TO THE EXTENT THAT DAVE IS
POLITICAL.
THEY SPENT FOUR YEARS ME MAKING
THEIR ENTIRE PARTY PLATFORM.
THEY SEE YOU AS A POLITICAL
OPPOSITION BECAUSE EVERY TIME
SOMEONE SAYS YOU CAN'T SAY THAT
HE WOULD SAY JUST WATCH ME, AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE FIND THAT REALL
REFRESHING.
>> HE DIDN'T POLITICIZE BOARDS,
THAT WAS SOMEBODY ELSE, SO NOW
WHAT HAPPENS IS IF YOU DON'T
PLAY THE POLITICAL GAME AND
ENTERTAINMENT AND SPORTS OR
ANYTHING, YOU ARE ALSO A
POLITICAL ANIMAL, YOU CAN'T EVE
STEP OUT OF IT, LIKE, OUR SOULS
IS ABOUT AS POLITICAL AS I DON'
KNOW, CAN YOU INSERT SOMETHING
INTO EDIT WITH A LITTLE JOKE
ABOUT LIKE THAT, THANK YOU.
>> WHEN I READ THESE ARTICLES
UNLIKE WHAT ARE THEY TALKING
ABOUT GREAT